so the former NBA player and his cancer
Freedom was in Rome recently when he
learned from the FBI that he needed to
come back to the U.S immediately he was
told that the Turkish government had put
a bounty on his head Freedom grew up in
Turkey before coming to the United
States and changing his name in honor of
this country he's been critical of the
Turkish government and this came for
Freedom joins us tonight thanks so much
for coming on so the Turkish government
you were informed by the U.S government
has put a bounty on your head half a
million dollar Bounty what does that
mean a bounty on your head
so like first of all thank you for
having me Mr Carlson
um I was doing a basketball camp in
Vatican actually for you know Christians
Catholic Muslim and Jewish kids and I
heard the news for the first time and I
had a I got in touch with FBI
immediately and they said come back to
America at this moment so I took a
flight the next day and so you know this
is the first time actually the Turkish
government put on a bouncy on my head
and put them in the Most Wanted
terrorist list just because if I talk
about the some of the human rights
violations and political appearances
happen in turkey and you know I'm not
the only one there are so many
journalists academics professors and
celebrities are on that list and when I
had a conversation with my friends on
the ground they said the Mafia the
serial killers actually professional
hitmans and cartel could be after my
case and I was like speechless I was
like this is this cannot be happening to
an American citizen in U.S soil
do you feel like the U.S government is
helping to protect you from this threat
from a foreign government
really good question you know some of
the members of the Congress actually
reacting to this news and asking by the
administration to speak up and actually
take some actions you know because I
remember first time President Biden
before he took to office actually the
first thing he said the the the problem
in Middle East is ardorn and we need to
do something about it and it's been
almost two years and he has not done a
thing yet so we have to prioritize human
rights and because turkey plays a very
important role because it could have
been a bridge of Islam and west but just
because of there is no freedom of speech
you know there are so many political
appearances and innocent people are in
the jail waiting for help it is not
possible so I'm asking please buy the
administration to take some solid
actions and and help my friends over
there help my family over there I
haven't seen them almost 10 years
well if they're okay with Chinese
genocide I doubt they're going to be too
upset about erdogan but that's just a
guess hope I'm wrong uh you just can't
afraid great to see you tonight thank
you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else